[Music]
hi
mysteryrecaft here today i am going to
explain a post-apocalyptic drama film
called carbon
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the premise of the movie is set in the
year 2067 when the earth has turned into
a barren land because of global warming
oxygen and drinking water are only
available to the wealthy because of the
amount of carbon in the air breathing
out in the open is almost impossible
houses and buildings are supplied with
partially clean air but outside them
people are required to wear masks to
stay alive a healthy human will
suffocate in about five minutes if they
do not wear a specialized oxygen mask
oxygen which once used to be a basic
part of nature has now turned into a
product
several million dollar companies
manufacture artificial oxygen in bulk
and sell it at an outrageous rate since
only the rich can afford it the
government provides oxygen to the poor
people at an affordable price but such
oxygen is not the best quality and can
kill you with time most humans have fled
to mars with gallons of oxygen and water
as people on earth become more violent
among all kinds of oxygen natural oxygen
which can still be found in the
himalayas is the most in demand it is
sold for millions and is even rarer than
nfts of cats i mean diamonds
a few years ago people were so eager to
acquire oxygen it caused several murders
and protests the government has since
banned the exploitation of natural
oxygen strictly even the rich aren't
allowed to trade or buy it when the
smuggling of such oxygen started the
government implemented a new rule
according to which people aren't allowed
to leave their houses after 6 pm anyone
who is seen in a public place during the
curfew will be shot dead immediately the
protagonist of the movie is a 30 year
old man named random shukla he was born
in mumbai india in the year 2037 because
of the condition of the environment he
suffered from heart failure as soon as
he took his first breath along with him
43 percent of the infants born that year
suffered from heart failure they have
been living with the help of an
artificial heart pacemaker until now
random has to always carry a bag with a
device that is attached to his chest for
the pacemaker to work he claims that he
has only heard the stories of the green
and blue earth and believes it is just a
myth the man cannot imagine a world
where oxygen is abundant and water is
not a luxury his job is to smuggle
natural oxygen on a small scale because
of the artificial heart he is allowed to
carry two cans of oxygen everywhere he
goes which helps him smuggle it at the
beginning of the movie random is woken
up in his cell that he shares with
several other workers the government
announces that the supply of oxygen to
houses will be stopped for a short
period of time in the morning people are
told to wear oxygen masks even when they
are indoors during that period it is a
regular day for random until his
associate calls him to a meeting with a
client named yakub who is willing to pay
them millions to smuggle two cans of
natural oxygen on a normal day someone
from the client side comes to pick up
the oxygen but since the security has
been tighter these days random has to
put his life in danger and go to the
client he accepts the job instantly for
the money his ultimate goal is to
collect enough money to go to mars and
start a new life random and his
associate go to the ruins of a building
to meet yakub he is a gangster and the
biggest oxygen smuggler in mumbai the
man has connections all over mars and
supplies the rich with pure himalayan
oxygen random tells him that he has a
license to carry natural oxygen so the
job won't be difficult for him yakub's
men tear his clothes to check if he is
telling the truth they are assured after
seeing a blinking device attached to his
chest the boss offers them 10 million
rupees each for the job but random
bargains they should get at least 40
million rupees yakub who is still unsure
of random's potential challenges him to
a match of arm wrestling according to
him a smuggler needs courage more than a
license to close a deal the match starts
during which yakub takes off his oxygen
mask and makes random do the same for a
fair match soon random has trouble
breathing and has to deliberately lose
to be able to wear the mask again
because he showed courage an impressed
yakub agrees to give him 40 million now
random has to bring two cans of natural
oxygen to the other side of the
checkpoint and hand it to a client from
mars named shaw he has to return with
the money before the evening curfew if
not the deal will be considered
unsuccessful and both random and his
associate will be killed in the
following scene random is in the metro
station which is also the checkpoint he
holds cans of oxygen in his bag which if
checked will be exposed as illegal
oxygen random is hoping that since he
has a license the security officer
wouldn't go to the extra length to check
the oxygen can he is so nervous that he
freezes when it is his turn to go in
just like he had predicted the officer
doesn't check the cans and lets him go
after scanning the license he even
advises random to not lose his license
or he could end up in jail for the rest
of his life some time later he reaches
an apartment where the client sha is
waiting for him shaw was flown to mars
when he was only five years old by his
wealthy parents he survives on high
quality artificial oxygen which is still
not as good as natural oxygen hence the
man is always keen on buying cans of
natural oxygen he has recently returned
to earth for the same reason random
notices a glass full of water on the
table he cannot help but stare at the
strange sight of clean water which is
usually reserved for wealthy people shaw
offers it to him which surprises random
he doesn't accept the glass and gets
straight to business instead shaw claims
that residents of mars only return to
earth for pleasure or for business he is
there for the former random gets the
hint and brings out the cans of fresh
oxygen the oxygen was collected and
packaged at 800 meters above sea level
making it non-toxic and a hundred
percent pure shaw inspects the cans and
appears to be impressed by them yet when
random asks for payment he hesitates the
oxygen might have moisture mixed into it
which means he cannot pay without
testing it first
random replies that even if the oxygen
has moisture it is the last batch coming
from the himalayas soon this kind will
also not be available for purchase he
suggests the client use the opportunity
wisely but his words make shaw suspect
him even more as the two get into a
heated conversation shaw mentions that
the earth is about to shake violently
very soon just as he says that the
coffee table starts shaking random
notices that the table is actually a box
that has something or someone inside of
it the two do not acknowledge the
shaking and continue the bargain they do
not go on for long before the box moves
again random had come to end the deal
without violence but seeing that the
client doesn't want to pay he brings out
a gun however shaw is not someone who
backs up he too points a gun at random
while random is nervous shaw appears to
be excited he claims that his life on
mars was boring and their conversation
is giving him an adrenaline rush in a
split second random shoots the man in
the forehead and kills him he had
realized that only one of them could
walk away alive so he took the only
opportunity that he had following that
he opens the box that had been moving
and is surprised to see a girl inside of
it she is tied up and gagged and seems
to have been kidnapped unsure what she
is capable of doing he points his gun at
her as well the girl freezes in shock
but is relieved when he frees her hands
random threatens her to stay low and
keep quiet because he doesn't want to
have to kill her as they talk the girl
reveals that the man who random just
killed is not shaw
the real shaw's dead body lies in the
bedroom it turns out that the man random
was talking to until now was pretending
to be shaw to stall him he was actually
a hit man who had killed shaw moments
before the girl also reveals that the
hitman was about to smuggle her to mars
before random arrived random knows that
if he returns to yakub without the money
he will end up dead hence he looks
around the house and finds several
gallons of clean water he almost doesn't
believe the treasure before him he wants
to smuggle them out but the containers
have an inbuilt security system which
means if someone tries to take them out
of the building without a passcode the
police will be alerted right then it is
announced that the evening curfew has
been implemented random's deal has
failed so he is bound to be killed if he
returns home he has to quickly think of
a way to run away from the city before
yakub finds him somewhere else yakub is
impatiently waiting for his arrival when
he is notified that the curfew is in
action he takes off random's friend's
oxygen mask and eventually kills the man
by suffocating him back in the apartment
random asks the girl about her true
identity she introduces herself as perry
and claims that she is a refugee who was
bought by shaw he planned to take her to
mars as his mistress but as soon as she
arrived there the hitman killed shaw and
held her hostage as the two talk
random's artificial heart alerts him of
overheating perry realizes that she is
making him nervous which makes him blush
even more when asked what she wants to
do now perry claims that she will travel
the world weirdly enough she keeps
repeating this same thing as her voice
turns more and more robotic random asks
her if she is fine and soon realizes
that she is just a robot who has been
programmed to think she is a human just
like your narrator perry malfunctions
and turns her power off and random is
left all alone he plans to run away as
soon as the curfew is lifted a few hours
later he breathes in the exclusive
oxygen out of curiosity it doesn't go
well because the whiff of clean oxygen
makes him pass out when he wakes up the
next morning yakub and his people are
standing in front of him they tie him to
a chair assuming that he killed shaw for
the gallons of water random tries to
explain what actually happened but yakub
doesn't believe him his men do not
notice the security system attached to
the water containers and start to carry
them to the elevator yakub leaves random
tied to a chair so he would be arrested
for killing shaw and the hitman however
as they try to walk away with the water
an alarm rings alerting the police
just then perry switches on and unties
random's hands the police catch yakub
and his gang since they only care about
the gallons of water being smuggled they
do not bother to search for random and
perry in the end the pair manages to
escape through a secret passage
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching